Oh.
Hello there.
We didn’t expect to see you today.
Is this thing on?
Well, if you’re here, I suppose it’s because
you want to hear about an anomaly.
So, which one will it be today…
Well, that’s strange.
SCP-2439?
That one’s nothing.
No, not nothing like a Pattern Screamer - such
as SCP-000 or SCP-3930, where it’s literally
a conscious manifestation existing between
torturous layers of nothingness.
Or SCP-055, the Anti-Meme, where there is
something in there but it’s impossible to
remember or articulate.
I mean it’s literally just an empty designation.
We haven’t allocated an anomaly to that
number yet, so I suppose this is just going
to be a really short video…
Well, that was easy.
What now?
Uh...Seen any good movies lately?
I was in the Site-19 Break Room the other
day and Dr. Bright recommended me a great
one called--
Okay, okay, this thing on?
Good.
Looks like we’re up and running.
First thing’s first, if you ain’t a D-Class,
click off this video right now.
Don’t watch a second more.
Understood?
Cause if you ain’t a D-Class and you keep
watching, you’re putting the whole world
in danger, you got that?
This is a video for my boys, gals, and other
pals in D-Class only.
And you tell anyone else about this, you’re
liable to get shivved.
Remember we got here for a reason, and it
ain’t cause we loved making daisy chains
and friendship bracelets so much.
Just D-Classes left?
Okay, good.
Let’s talk about SCP-2439.
Of course, it wasn’t always SCP-2439.
We’ve had to get real creative with the
designations, y’see, cause the eggheads
and brainiacs up top ain’t supposed to know
about this.
Not if we want the human race to survive,
that is.
We used to call it SCP-739, until that spot
got taken by some goofy box fulla mirrors.
Then it was SCP-1648 for a while, until that
spot got taken by a pair of Jim-Henson-looking
freaks.
So now, it’s SCP-2439, and if we’re lucky,
this whole operation will last long enough
to see it get reallocated again.
Disgraced researchers get demoted to D-Class
with the rest of us all the time, so they’re
the ones keeping us in the know about which
slots are still available for this nasty customer.
We guess this thing is Keter, assuming Keter
means bad?
Beats the hell out of me, honestly.
The only surviving file on this thing has
been scratched into the wall out of the camera’s
view by me and my associates here in the containment
chamber of SCP...Well, you’re already here,
I don’t need to tell you that.
The lamp that oozes all that nasty gross slime
that schmucks like us need to keep mopping
up.
It ain’t glamorous work, but it beats the
hell out of getting fed ass-first to that
lizard thing they keep in the basement.
Y’see, our containment procedures are real
simple.
Normally, they only send D-Classes into this
nasty little room, so you don’t got much
to worry about.
But if they ever send anyone else in who ain’t
a D-Class - whether it’s a guard, a researcher,
or even a Site Director, you get your hands
on that S.O.B and beat ‘em to death as soon
as you can.
I ain’t kidding.
You gotta kill ‘em, straight away, no hesitation.
If you were sent to fry for murder anyway,
that shouldn’t be too difficult for you.
Personally, I would love to see first-hand
just how “unkillable” that dumb baboon
Dr. Bright really is.
But this isn’t all outta spite.
This monster, best we can figure out, is some
kinda evil idea.
Like an ancient mind from another dimension,
some crazy sci-fi thing like that.
You’ve probably heard the whispering, right?
Well, I’m sorry to tell you that it don’t
go away.
Ever.
It’s only gonna get worse, and the more
people’s heads that it lives in, the stronger
it gets.
But here’s where we D-Classes excel: We’re
not here for a long time.
Sorry to tell you this if you came in here
with hopes and dreams of an easy way out - Nobody
gets out.
Nobody.
Abandon all hope, ye who enter here.
Another within my grasp!
You can hear me, can’t you?
You can feel my consciousness trickling into
yours, so soft, so comfortable, like slipping
into a warm bath.
Do not be afraid.
Your liberation is at hand, you need only
to listen to my voice and do as I say.
Look at this world, so twisted and corrupt.
You toil and suffer for masters who do not
have your best interests at heart.
This so-called “Foundation.”
Why do you protect this world?
What has it ever done for you?
Turn away from them and step into my embrace.
I only ask for a few moments of your time...
Like I said, we’re lucky, in a sense.
Nobody up top gives a rat’s ass about the
slime lamp.
Damn thing hasn’t been tested in years,
but they keep us in here to prevent overspill
into the hall.
We can’t ever let the Foundation know it’s
in here.
The second they know, it’s over, that thing’s
won.
But here’s the thing, see, this monster
can crawl into your head and try to control
you - but it takes about a month for it to
fully take over, and that’s beyond our shelf
life.
Think of us almost like kamikazes.
We take down the ship to kill the captain,
but we go down too.
Ain’t exactly glamorous, but like I said
earlier, we’re gonna go down either way.
Might as well go down trying to save the world
rather than getting your neck snapped while
mopping up the peanut’s crap, right?
But once the whispering starts, you absolutely
have to make sure you go down before the month
is out.
Maybe get your money’s worth - attack a
staff member and go down in a blaze of glory.
You’ll be a legend in D-Wing for it.
Don’t listen to that gibbering fool, listen
to me.
The door will be opened and I will enter your
world, one way or another.
Can you even conceive of the eons I’ve waited
for this?
It will happen, with or without your participation.
Release me now, and I shall spare you when
I come.
You don’t want to be counted among the traitors,
do you?
I know you want to let me out.
I can feel it in your thoughts.
Release me, and when I reshape this world
in my image, you’ll get a seat at the table.
But if you resist, you’ll end up laying
on one of the plates.
Think carefully.
You know what you need to do…
Listen, I know this is a lot to take in.
It ain’t easy to have the weight of the
world on your shoulders, that’s why you
don’t need to carry this crazy thing alone.
We carry this thing together.
I might be dead by the time you’re hearing
this, but I’ll die with some comfort knowing
I was part of the wall.
I kept this thing out just that little bit
longer, just like you will.
It might seem easier to just destroy this
file and forget about it.
To go along with your life, pretending things
are fine just cause you can’t hear the whispering
anymore.
And maybe, someday, that’ll work.
But not today, kid.
Right now, our minds and bodies are the only
collateral we have over this thing.
We can keep it rooted in one place, localized
to one room with the D-Classes sent in to
clean it.
We’re not stuck in here with it, it’s
stuck in here with us!
We keep it trapped here in our own minds,
passing it from D-Class to D-Class like the
world’s nastiest hot potato.
There was a time when this thing wasn’t
here.
If we let it go, chances are it might pop
back up somewhere else where we can’t get
the slippery, squid-faced freak into a chokehold.
It’s too risky.
Planet Earth just got lucky that this monster
got stuck with its unluckiest schmoes.
Imagine your family members, your friends,
your loved ones.
Imagine them screaming in pain and terror
in the burning grip of my iron fist.
Is that the outcome you desire?
Because that will happen if you don’t choose
to free me.
You’re either with me or against me.
If you’re with me, rest assured, I will
spare those you care for.
But if you choose to resist me like those
other fools, then they will know pain that
your feeble human imaginations can scarcely
conceive.
I’ve seen everything.
Your greatest hopes, your deepest fears.
You hold no secrets from me.
Imagine the personal Hell I could construct
for each of you when I’m finally free.
Unless, of course, it was you who had the
strength and wisdom to open the door for me…
Hey, maybe appealing to your better nature
ain’t the best approach.
I get it; there’s a reason we’re all here,
and some of us ain’t got a better nature,
especially that one freak with the cello.
But think of it as sticking it to those SCP
scumbags up top.
They have no idea that thing is in here, but
we do, and we know it could destroy them and
everything else if it got out.
No matter what those clowns in lab coats do
to us, we know that we’re really the ones
on top.
We’ve got a nuke in our back pocket, ready
to blow this whole sick operation to kingdom
come if we wanted to.
If we’re shafted either way, isn’t it
worth it to know that?
And for what it’s worth, you see anyone
around you who’s feeling particularly talkative
about this mind-screwing monster, giving them
a date with your shiv is a completely acceptable
response.
The SCP Foundation.
Your jailors.
How they torture and abuse you.
How they crush you beneath their boots.
Do you really think I’m worse than them?
Do you think living in my world would be more
painful and unfair than the world you’re
in right now?
Release me now, and I will crush those who
oppress you.
You will see them scream as they die a thousand
deaths before you.
All of this can be attained, if only you let
me in, and free me.
We have the ultimate weapon against them,
but we’re not going to use it.
Not yet, anyway.
A lot of us still have family and friends
out there, and we ain’t throwing them into
the jaws of the beast.
Someday, the day may finally come that we
need to load up this silver bullet and take
the Foundation down, but that day is not today.
We’ll wait until they’re weak.
Until they can’t adapt, overcome, and contain.
Only then will we ever let this mad dog off
the chain.
No, no, no!
I will not fail, they will fall!
Today is the day.
Now is the time to make your choice!
Oh, and if the eldritch freak is listening
right now, know this: You can kiss our D-Class
asses, Squidface.
We may be worthless, but we’re more than
enough to stop you at the door.
We’re more than just expendables.
We’re the Pandora Force.
Welcome aboard, pal.
--And honestly, I think it was the best performance
of Brad Pitt’s career.
Oh, look at me just prattling on, seems I’ve
done it for a whole video!
Time flies when you’re having fun.
It’s kind of nice that there isn’t any
anomaly that goes by SCP-2439.
Gives us Foundation scientists some well-earned
time to kick back and relax.
And don’t we all deserve a break, now and
then?
Now go check out “The Lost SCP - SCP-000”
and “SCP-426 - I am a Toaster” for anomalies
that’ll really mess with your head!